في غضون ايام قليله تجاوز هذا التطبيق
تطبيقات عملاقه من حيث معدلات التحميل في
الولايات المتحده انه تطبيق ليمون 8
التابع لشركه باي دانس الصينيه المالكه
لتطبيق تيك توك فما قصته
التطبيق يسمح بمشاركه مقاطع الفيديو
والصور البعض اعتبره خطوه تنافسيه
لانستجرام للتشابه الكبير بينه وبين
التطبيق خبراء قالوا ان التحميل الصاروخي
للتطبيق هو حيله ذكيه من الشركه الصينيه
للتخلص من الضغوط الامريكيه لارغامها على
بيع تيك توك مؤكدين ان شركه باي دانس
استهدفت المؤثرين ومستخدمي تيك توك بشكل
رسمي لنقلهم الى تطبيقها الجديد ليمون 8
وكما هو الحال مع تيك توك ابدى مسؤولون
امريكيون تخوفهم من قدره هذا التطبيق على
التجسس لحساب الصين